and do very well I very see you being
able to just put put out what being in
the middle of an aggressive form of
multiple sclerosis but Summa Blair is
opening up about her health after making
an emotional return to the red carpet on
Sunday night the actress who revealed in
October that she had been diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis gave her first TV
interview on Tuesday speaking candidly
to Good Morning America's Robin Roberts
MS is an incurable autoimmune disease
that affects the central nervous systems
ability to communicate with the rest of
the body making movement and speech
difficult at times the 46 year old
explained that she was in the midst of a
flare-up that affected her voice so my
speech is you'll notice is I have spent
spasmodic dysphonia right now it is
interesting to put it out there to be
here to say this is what my particular
case looks like right now
selma says she saw tons of doctors
before receiving her diagnosis I had
tears I wasn't they weren't tears of
panic they were tears of nothing I now
had to give in to a body that had lots
of control and there was some relief in
that she admits she suffered through the
symptoms for years quote giving it
everything to seem normal
around her 7 year old son Arthur
including self medicating guy dropped my
son off at school a mile away and before
I got home I'd have to pull over and
take a nap and I was ashamed and I was
doing the best I couldn't have as a
great mother but it was killing me and
so when I got the diagnosis I cried with
some relief Salma said she previously
sought advice from Michael J Fox who has
been living with Parkinson's disease for
decades I said I don't know who to tell
but I'm dropping things I'm doing
strange things he got in touch with me
but like really he he gets me hope Salma
also opened up to Vanity Fair about her
life since going public with the
diagnosis revealing to the
that famous friends including sarah
michelle gellar Amy Schumer whose dad
has MS and Kris Jenner have been a major
support to her and apparently it's a
two-way street of positivity Jenner told
Vanity Fair quote she showed me what
courage is and how to be brave I changed
a bit of the way I lived my life because
of her that seems to be Selma's message
moving forward the actress says she
hopes that her appearance at the Vanity
Fair Oscar party on Sunday brings
awareness to the disease after she
walked the red carpet with her cane she
shared this pic on Instagram writing in
part quote there are moments that define
us this is one of those indelibly water
marked in my heart and because her
doctor said she could regain 90% of her
abilities within the next year she is
hoping to reunite with Robin on Good
Morning America in 2020 to measure her
progress really sweet yeah I love that
no one has to talk with her
but I do cuz I love a camera now Selma
is so strong and we are sending her and
her sweet little Arthur all of our love
and of course when Selma gives updates
on her health we'll be right there to
fill you in so be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm at
Halle underscore Stephens and I met
Courtney underscore tezo know bye for
now guys